[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau rendez vous du 7 8
sociétés votre rendez vous hebdomadaire
où nous discutons des sujets qui font
l'actualité
plus de 66% ce sont les chiffres de
l'abstention des deux derniers scrutins
en france et élections régionales et
départementales de juin 2021 chez les 18
24 ans les chiffre monte même à 87%
c'est un record jamais rencontrés sous
la vème république avec les
présidentielles et législatives prévues
sur l'année 2022 la lutte contre
l'abstention et notant l'enjeu alors
comment la réduire on en parle avec nos
invités bruno myle yens bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes député de la 9e
circonscription des yvelines et
initiateur d'un groupe de réflexion sur
la problématique notamment de
l'abstention florian rivière bonsoir
bonsoir vous est coresponsable 78 de
l'association a voté alors le premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle c'est
le 10 avril prochain la campagne pas son
plein et une question se pose comment
lutter contre cette abstention lors des
élections le 18 janvier dernier dernier
une table ronde était organisée au x
campus de saint germain en laye en
différant présence de différents élus
ils ont essayé de trouver des solutions
pour inciter les citoyens à aller voter
un sujet de marco jésus à
65 7 % d'abstention au second tour des
dernières régionales
un chiffre préoccupant une table ronde a
donc été organisée mardi 18 janvier au x
campus à saint-germain-en-laye cas vrai
sujet abstention et qu'il faut
absolument affronter puisque ça indique
à malaise dans notre démocratie élus
locaux citoyens et spécialistes ont
cherché des solutions pour inciter au
vote véritablement pose la question du
sens quel sens cela at-il à des voté
pour quoi allons nous voter par exemple
c'est pas évident pour les régionales et
départementales
parce qu'on comprend pas quel est le
rôle de ces institutions comprendre le
partage des compétences et pour ça il
faut avoir une meilleure éducation et je
crois que c'était un point très
important que ce soit une meilleure
éducation à la citoyenneté et sa suite
dé l'école dès l'école primaire il
faudrait donc éduquer mais aussi
simplifier c'est surtout la
compréhension fine plus fine des
institutions du rôle de chacun une
simplification qui me semble ressortir
des attentes des citoyens ce soir dans
l'assistance les personnes présentes
prenait part aux débats initiatives a
été bien accueillie je pense que c'est à
renouveler continue à travailler sur ce
sur ses talons si on veut changer la
situation je sais que les jeunes sont
évidemment très occupée par l'abstention
après moi je sais je suis un jeune assez
politisé donc je venais pas vraiment
pour moi mais bon c'était aussi pour
savoir pour en apprendre plus c'est
l'élection présidentielle résistent
encore à l'abstention en 2017 elle
s'élevait à 25 % au second tour la
prochaine aura lieu en avril
bruno myle yens on le disait justement
les derniers scrutins de 2021 ont révélé
un taux d'abstention record est ce que
vous en tant qu'élu vous trouvez que ce
sont des chiffres inquiétants oui les
chiffres - le cna qui m'a terrifié parce
que au-delà de la crise sanitaire dans
laquelle ces les élections le contexte
dans lequel ces élections ont eu lieu
ça montre un projet mal un profond
malaise des français vis-à-vis du vote
non moi je suis pas très langue de bois
je dirais que la première des raisons
pour lesquelles il ya sept abstentions
c'est elle et elle nous a contenu les
élus c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'on
arrête de raconter des sornettes aux
français moi j'ai regardé attentivement
le lancement de campagne les catalogue à
la prévert des mesures qu'on va faire
dans ton site pertinemment qu'on pourra
pas les tenir et les français sont pas
idiots ils savent très bien qu'on ne
tiendra pas donc voilà il ya déjà ce
premier point là et puis après il ya nos
outils de démocratie qui sont pas bons
je pense qu'on reparlera la démocratie
citoyenne ça fait partie des outils à
développer mais pas que mais justement
dans les causes qui mène à l'abstention
il ya aussi le sentiment que c'est la
même politique qui est menée quel que
soit le parti pouvoir donc ça ne sert
rien à rien d'aller voter
alors je vais vous faire un aveu de mon
expérience de parlementaire c'est que
vous pourrez avoir toutes les idéologies
du monde d'accord
vous êtes confrontés quand vous êtes au
pouvoir à la réalité du terrain et des
actions vous avez amené des réponses que
vous avez apporté par évident en
fonction de votre sensibilité on est
bien d'accord mais la sensibilité dans
les actions que vous menez je pense
qu'elle représente à peu près 20% de
l'action que vous menez pour 80% de
choses qui sont dictées par la situation
vous n'avez pas le choix vous avez une
réponse immédiate à donner on l'a vu
avec les crises qu'on a traversés et ça
quelle que soit l'idéologie il n'y a pas
36 manières de répondre donc ça c'est la
première des choses et je pense que les
idéologies qu'on a eu jusqu'à maintenant
elles sont confrontées à un changement
radical du monde dans lequel nous vivons
où tout s'accélère de manière
exponentielle et on peut plus rester
dans des idéologies aussi comment dire
aussi dogmatique aussi fermé qu'elles
existent pour certains en tout cas on
voit bien qu'il ya deux projets qui
s'affrontent aujourd'hui deux projets de
société qu'ils affrontent un projet on
va dire social libéral qui englobe à la
fois si on prend la gauche parti
socialiste
à droite les nerfs puis
la majorité présidentielle c'est à dire
elle est raide modem agir et tout ce qui
compose la majorité présidentielle et à
côté de ça vous avez deux autres projets
des projets qui sont complètement
différents qui sont celui de jean-luc
mélenchon et celui de marine le pen qui
se rejoignent bizarrement par moments
mais qui sont des projets complètement
antagoniste par rapport au projet on va
dire des partis de gouvernement entre
guillemets
alors parmi ces chiffres très
inquiétants c'est celui des 18 24 ans
87% des jeunes ne se sont pas déplacés
en 2021 florian rivière
l'association a voté dont vous êtes le
coresponsable 78 vise principalement ces
jeunes commencent on explique que les 18
24 ans qui vote pour la première fois
pour la plupart ne se déplace pas
écouter leur fait mal la chose à savoir
finalement c'est que en fait les jeunes
auront dit souvent qu'ils sont engagés
ou qui font que ça intéresse
qui se passe nous mêmes canaux que les
finales et que les
la société toujours engagé mais c'est
les modalités d'engagement à dire qu'ils
vont changer finalement ou en fait il va
y avoir de la sphère associative venir
il va y avoir aussi de la nécessité
d'avoir tout de suite dans son contrat
donc c'est pour ça qu'on pouvoir d
un désir d'avoir
finalement nous devons avoir un impact
pour certains votes n'est plus une
lors de cette table ronde il a souvent
été mentionné que il était question de
l'enseignement de l'éducation aux droits
de vote ce que c'est un droit en france
à l'importance de voter de ne pas se
rendre compte que les jeux ne sont pas
nécessairement au courant de pour qu'on
voie pour les législatives pourquoi pour
les européennes c'est un avis que vous
partagez a voté il ya c'est peut-être un
peu trop floue ces différents modes de
scrutin et ses différentes compétences
en fonction des collectivités
je pense qu'effectivement il ya un
travail effet activement pour france
entre que le maximum de personnes soit
obligé des différentes compétences de
chacune des des articles des
intercommunalités après nos le cheval de
bataille sur lequel a décidé de se mener
fait le sujet de la prescription d'un
d'inscription que finalement ça c'est un
sujet qui me choque vraiment une jeune
william il ya un jeune sur deux qui
entre 18 et 29 ans et qui entre 25 et 20
ans brandon qui est malartic vous faites
c'est à dire soit qui est inscrit dans
la commune de ses parents mais qui a
fait ses études ou alors qui est tout
simplement vide il ya oublié de ce point
de changer de domiciliation donc ça fait
au total valable ça fait plus de 7
millions de 200 citoyens 60 du corps
électoral finalement ça fait un
véritable buzz mocratique pas
l'inscription donc les jeunes enfants
font partie justement offert sa sauce
tout on est mal inscrits on a jusqu'à
trois fois plus de chances d'être
abstentionnistes iqu donc on va essayer
des choses c'est qu'ils peuvent être
concrète pour
lutter contre l'inflation mais bruno
myle yens la malle inscriptions c'est un
vrai sujet plus de 7 millions de
français partent des lecteurs sont mal
inscrits en france sur les 47 millions
et sur les 25 29 ans ça représente 43%
vient on vient de simplifier sa pour
permettre aux gens de s'inscrire assez
facilement dans une commune dans
laquelle ils viennent ils viennent
d'arriver et pas être obligé d'aller
voter on le disait chez les temps et
cette taille peuvent le faire maintenant
relativement facilement en allant à la
mairie le savent peut-être pas mais en
tout cas c'est beaucoup plus facile
aujourd'hui de voter depuis son lieu de
résidence que ça ne l'était encore il ya
quelques années voilà il faut
effectivement et éduquer les gens et ça
il ya une réflexion nous qu'on s'est
fait et aussi effectivement et vous
l'avez rappelé la méconnaissance des
land art des différents mandats électifs
auquel auxquelles certaines personnes
concours il ya un imbroglio total sur
les sur les collectivités où on ne voit
plus très bien ce que sont les maires on
voit plus très bien ce que font les
intercommunalités après vous allez
départements les régions tout ça est
très flou et pour joue là d'une info le
3 février prochain l'assemblée nationale
dans la nuit noire de la niche modem la
plupart de nos textes à la grande
majorité de nos textes seront justement
sur les scrute pas que sur les scrutins
électoraux mais comment sur les scrutins
électoraux et comment réduire
l'abstention donc ça passe par une
modernisation de notre démocratie et de
la façon dont on vote on va commencer
par essayer je pense mais ça ça passera
pas on est pressé de remettre en place
le vote par correspondance parce qu'il
est l'unité dans dans des dans des
dizaines de pays sans qui la moindre
trace de fraude donc je pense que c'est
un dogme le fait de refuser ça ça passe
aussi par mettre une meilleure
représentativité notamment à l'assemblée
nationale de ce qui se passe dans le
pays je vous donne un exemple et
pourtant dieu sait si c'est pas ma tasse
de thé mais il est anormal que le
rassemblement national qui était
finaliste pour la présente
présidentielle n'est pas de groupe à
l'assemblée nationale
impérativement qu'on avance sur la
proportionnelle qu'on trouve un moyen de
la mettre en place qui déstabilise pas
les institutions mais qui permettent aux
français de se sentir représentés dans
ce cas la maison du peuple aujourd'hui
ne se sentent pas totalement représentés
il ya la participation citoyenne
j'imagine qu'on y reviendra mais on a
aussi des propositions là dessus et
voilà il faut qu'on avance là-dessus et
il faut il ya aussi un sujet qu'on va
mettre en avant vous souvenez c'était
sous l'ère de nicolas sarkozy on avait
parlé du conseiller territorial de
manière à essayer de faire l'a dit en
fin da ré ttc sans pigments de mille
feuilles entre le conseiller
départemental conseiller régional
peut-être que vous à un conseiller
territorial qui remplissaient les deux
fonctions ce serait plus simple que ça
parle aurait pu échanger aller vers
peut-être une simplification des mandats
j'aurais juste qu'on revienne sur la
malle inscriptions parce que florian
rivière à voter a lancé un chabot sur
what's app pour encourager notamment la
participation électorale en vue une
nouvelle fois les jeunes ce qu'on parle
d'application que la jeunesse utilise
principalement est-ce que ça aussi il
faut que les institutions s'adapte
peut-être au monde d'aujourd'hui on
parlait du vote par correspondance il ya
aussi le vote par internet les jeunes
aujourd'hui se renseigne par les réseaux
sociaux
peut-être que de passer vélo lewenza
mais j'imagine que c'est pour ça qu'il a
été lancée
il a été dans cette fiction comme on
disait pour répondre à ce bug
démocratique qui pour avoir un outil
finalement concret aux foires dès à
présent permettent aux gens de pouvoir
en quelques clics voir sa voix après
avoir donné donné juste une info jean
n'a plus de 18 ans ou non et puis le
code postal ou on est inscrits savoir si
justement on est bien masquée au mal
inscrits et donc après finalement la
personne va une fois qu'il va discuter
avec son chat ce vote va être redirigé
vers dalian services publics tous les
liens que va que l'on envoie ses liens
du service public justement par exemple
hier pour justement soit changé son
inscription soit avoir de l'inscription
sur laquelle on a été donc finalement
c'est ce chat qui en partenariat avec
meta et groupe ouest france et vingt
minutes c'est c'est quelque chose qui
permet d'avoir un moyen concret qui ont
déjà permettre aux gens et aux jeunes
notamment physiquement d'aller sur un an
les canaux qui connaissent
particulièrement est de faire en sorte
que finalement derrière ils sont ils
sont également bien ce qui est un petit
mot effectivement après sortie ciné à la
télé chronique est votre ligne à côté
moi je ne sais pas s'il est noir mais
qui promeut le ski et participation
citoyenne et dans un second temps qui
est vote en ligne le on sait que de
statistiques effectivement que 50% des
gens qui s'abstiennent le vôtre et s'il
peut le faire dit internet donc ça aussi
il ya des ajustements pour pouvoir faire
en sorte que les gens s'abstiennent
n'est le sujet des sécurités
effectivement on travaille dessus avec
et avec plein de sujets que des
organismes d silva sécurité pour être
prêt le moment venu mais c'est ces deux
sujets de la manade cription et le vote
en ligne je pense que c'est des sujets
qui peuvent être mis en place assez
rapidement il y en a un qui fait
beaucoup débat donc effectivement il
peut y avoir des beaucoup de discussions
soient partis mal à ce qu'il change
parce que c'est un ses colonies un bug
démocratique c'est pas normal
qu'aujourd'hui il ya autant de personnes
qu'ils soient soient mal inscrits et
finalement qu'ils puissent pas partie
une élection ça pour moi
anissa administratives qu alors que
finalement ils ont envie de participer
on a beaucoup parlé de la participation
citoyenne ça a été à de nombreuses
reprises
prononcé vous nos milliers nous avait
notamment lancé confluence un groupe de
réflexion qu'est né de l'abstention
record de 2021 est ce que vous avez déjà
pu établir des premiers bilans de ces
rendez vous organisé vous avez peut-être
déjà fait remonter des informations au
ministère
la participation citoyenne pour être
père moi j'y suis favorable après on a
eu on a eu l'expérience de la convention
citoyenne pour tout le monde s'en
souvient formidable expérience
formidable expérience dans cinquante
citoyens tirés au sort qui ont été
éduqués à la chose environnementale de
manière remarquable partout des plus
grands spécialistes qu'on avait et qui
ont dû qui ont pu en conscience du coût
de travailler sur les discussions fait
sauf que on a eu un petit problème à
l'atterrissage je le dis aussi nettement
que je pense c'est que au moment des
auditions pour faire leurs propositions
quand on fait quelque chose comme ça je
pense que les citoyens ayant été
informées étant au courant de la
situation il faut qu'ils puissent aussi
auditionné tous les acteurs qui peuvent
rentrer dans la résolution d'une
situation où d'un problème qu'on leur
impose or là il on s'est aperçu que dans
les auditions qui ont été menées
justement pour établir leur leurs
propositions
94% des auditions l'ont été avec des ong
environnementales
ce qui en soi pour moi n'est pas un
problème mais je trouve que c'est
disproportionné par rapport au monde
économique qui lui aussi a des choses à
dire tous les jours vous avez des
sociétés et des grands groupes qui
travaillent et qui avance pour lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique
et ces gens là n'ont pas été auditionnés
le patron de renault pour prendre un
exemple je prends renault parce que
c'est a fait un signe sur ma
circonscription n'a pas été auditionné
trouve pas ça normal non participation
citoyenne louis avec une vraie
méthodologie qui permet aux citoyens
d'être éclairé de tous les côtés de
manière à pouvoir faire des propositions
les plus les plus réelles et et
structuré possible
oui puis on parlait aussi
de cette participation citoyenne en
décembre 2021 il ya un rapport qui a été
remis avec 28 propositions toujours pour
lutter contre l'abstention parmi ces
propositions il ya aussi la création
d'une plate forme démocratique pour
interpeller les élus
florian libyenne est ce que c'est aussi
l'occasion peut-être de rapprocher les
les élus avec les électeurs qu'on
parlait tout à l'heure de distance
peut-être est-ce que ça pousserait
peut-être d'autres électeurs à se rendre
dans les bureaux de vote s'ils savent
qu'ils peuvent interpeller ce qu'on
interpelle facilement son maire qu'on
peut croiser dans la commune ça peut
paraître plus difficile pour un élu
régional ou un sénateur ou un député
oui effectivement totalement c'est toute
amende d'aider tout ce qui est plate
forme numérique c'est ce qu'ont route de
chez à volonté et leur on a vu qu
effectivement on aime plus justement
avoir des taux de participation qui
était justement d importants qu'ils
étaient plus de fenêtres dispard proche
de la moyenne sur les consultations de
local parce que en fait finalement on a
mixé puis ces camions finalement on a
mixé le cadeau du jet de vue physique
avec les réseaux publics et a pris avec
cette plateforme qui est qui était venu
la plateforme vous appliquez son
horrible et ça permet finalement aux
personnes est effectivement pas au fait
de de soi de la conciliation sont deux
sujets en cours au finalement des sujets
de pour s'exprimer et de pouvoir faire
de faire un entraînement voit d'autre
que des valable une échelle communale
ses vols à l'échelle régionale et
finalement plus on s'éloigne plus les
citoyens sont loin puis les institutions
sont loin des citoyens puis à cette
nécessité de finalement derrière avoir
quelque chose qui soit le bas un
dialogue et qu'ils soient finalement
continue et qu'ils ne puissent pas se
perdre et ce qui se passe pour moi
puisqu'il budget bâti faut si finalement
d'ailleurs il ya un pourcentage d déçoit
des villes ou des régions de
départements qui voit allouer une partie
du budget pour justement faire
participer lit ce moment ils doivent
montrer qu'ils ont une manière d'agir
finalement sur instigation ces sujets
wayne rooney au milieu ça rejoint ce que
vous disiez où finalement
les lecteurs français ne voit pas
nécessairement tout le travail qui peut
y avoir derrière aussi fait par les
parlementaires je vais vous faire une
petite belge et pourtant qu'est ce qu'on
peut être interpellé sur certains
réseaux pour se faire menacer de mort je
me dis quand même là ça n'hésite pas non
mais plus plus plus sérieusement lors de
la campagne des municipales j'avais
proposé à certains maires ils n'ont pas
mis en place j'avais proposé à certains
maires d'organiser dans leur commune des
commissions miroir ou s'il ya des
commissions on est dans les bureaux
exécutifs des mairies à la commission
d'urbanisme la commission des travaux et
c est de dire solliciter vos citoyens
solliciter nos citoyens pour faire une
commission miroir vous leur donnez un
sujet sur lequel ils doivent plancher en
même temps que la municipalité planche
sur le même sujet à un moment vous vous
rencontrez vous confrontez vos idées moi
je voyais et deux avantages à cela
d'abord premièrement c'était la
possibilité d' éduquer les citoyens sur
toutes les difficultés que peuvent
rencontrer des élus à faire avancer un
projet à cause des règlements à cause
des lois à cause des normes à cause de
tout ce que vous pouvez imaginer mais
dont les gens n'ont pas forcément
confiance en conscience par donc c'est
une façon d'éduquer les citoyens et de
l'autre côté notre avantage c'était la
possibilité de donner aux élus justement
des idées peut-être novatrice qui
n'auraient pas forcément lui bon
personne n'a mis en place pour l'instant
mais c'est ce genre de procédé auquel je
crois beaucoup
ferrari est bien aussi il faut améliorer
peut-être cet ancrage aussi des
parlementaires c'est une autre des
propositions faites en décembre que ce
soit dans les deux sens les échanges on
peut interpeller les élus mais que les
élus puissent peut être aussi
interpeller les électeurs
tout à fait effectivement je pense que
le dialogue doit vraiment être est des
deux côtés finalement le et finalement
aussi pouvoir promettre aussi de
centraliser des fois évidemment les
demandes autour d'une plate forme d'une
application dagneux et pas forcément sur
le réseaux sociaux peut y avoir beaucoup
de bruit justement avoir des gens qui
sont juste là pour le troll c'est
vraiment faire ça va faire du mal ou de
faire des invectives simplement donc je
pense que c'est un bon moyen
effectivement essayé de pouvoir
approcher les approcher les ni
les élus et finalement si on extrapole
un petit peu finalement aussi à voter
avec eux
me sentir vraiment balade combattent ce
fait non inscription via le chat box a
pas mais aussi en tant que tel d'après
finalement une fois que la personne
commence est de s'impliquer elles
inscrivent donc elle va pouvoir plus
s'impliquer dans la vie locale et donc
après derrière on va pouvoir après aller
sur toutes ses plateformes où tous les
moyens pour voir communiquer donc
finalement le sait ce que
c'est chaque créneau se rejoint ce
que dit florian je suis désolé c'est
important ce qu'il dit parce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut non seulement
continuer le présentiel et la relation
physique parce qu'elle est importante
mais il faut qu'on adapte on s'adapte
aux nouveaux outils aux outils
numériques parce qu'on touche toute une
partie de la population qui ne va pas se
déplacer sur mon public
les réunions publiques par exemple il ya
eu il ya eu quand il ya eu un grand
débat national j'en ai fait une dizaine
de réunions publiques sur la
circonscription là c'était que du
présentiel il n'y avait pas deux il y
avait pas d'extraction sur la confluence
par exemple sur les sur les 4 5e réunion
en a fait on a fait à la fois en
présentiel et on l'a fait aussi sur les
sur les réseaux que ce soit sur facebook
sur sur instagram etc nous avions des
modérateurs qui ne remontaient les
questions en plus confiance avait un ça
va un avantage c'est que moi je me
déportais j'étais là comme grand témoin
élus grands témoins mais ce n'est pas
moi qui menait la danse y avait toujours
un un
spécialiste du sujet dont on discute et
qui lui communiquer directement avec la
salle est directement avec les
internautes moi j'étais là pour récolter
effectivement les avis et effectivement
les distribuer on a eu comme ça je vous
dis ça a très bien marché une session
sur transition écologique et agriculture
c'est un sujet qui peut être quand même
assez assez durs et il y avait à la fois
des associations écologiques et d aider
des agriculteurs qui étaient là le fait
que ce soit pas moi qui mène les débats
et que je me déporte a permis que chacun
écoute l'autre et à la fin de la réunion
aussi bien les agriculteurs que les
écologistes sont noirs en disant merci
pour avoir fait ça parce qu'on a compris
certaines choses qu'on n'avait pas perçu
et comme le temps file on va terminer
sur cette question c'est que ça a
souvent été soumis certains de nos
voisins européens le fonds faut-il un
jour peut-être rendre le droit de vote
un devoir de vote et le rendent
obligatoires peut-être florian libyen
pour commencer
je pense que ça voudrait dire sinon
c'est une question philosophique qui si
la nouvelle association a voté on se bat
finalement sur un conseil et
scientifiques sont avec des gens qui
sont reconnus de l'abstention de valeur
monsieur pons ou madame super team dans
ma girouette c'est toutes ces questions
ont finalement houleux avec pas une
autre conseiller société finalement où
finalement le on est amené finalement à
réfléchir assez assez junas pour
justement le extrapoler les sujets je
pense qu'en tout cas le seul ce serait
quelque chose il serait à en discuter
pour en sorte que et les peut-être les
gens qui considèrent fierro que le droit
de vote et peut-être quelque chose je
m'occupais de cap bep bac et peut-être
des yeux ou qui finalement qu'il trouve
que c'est plus forcément le
aussi important qu'avant le rappeler
finalement le derrière qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que ça leur permet derrière
finalement qu'est-ce que ce droit de
vote qui leur permet d'ailleurs
finalement montré bah ouais comme quand
ils font une participation dans une
plate-forme ou n'importe quoi leur dire
vous voyez vous avez été écoutés
maintenant on va vous pouvez
faire part de leur position sur une
chaussée nord avec le vote je pense
qu'il serait intéressant de leur part
prendre ce constat est donc moins
favorables à ce sujet je pense après
votre avis monsieur milian doit-on
rendre le vote obligatoire débat moi ce
que j'aimerais déjà c'est qu'on commence
par moderniser notre démocratie qu'on
emploie les outils qui sont les outils
qu'utilisent les jeunes aujourd'hui
puisqu'on parlait des jeunes vous voyez
bien que les jeunes n'ont pas forcément
envie d'aller le dimanche
au bureau de vote pour aller voter s'ils
peuvent voter par internet sur les
arrange s'il peut faire du vote par
anticipation ça les arrange ça leur
libère du temps et il faut déjà qu'on
démocratique un petit peu notre
démocratie qu'on modernise démocratie
une fois qu'on aura fait ça si ça marche
toujours pas mais oui des bâtons quand
il ya des exemples de démocratie où le
vote est obligatoire c'est pas pour
autant que la démocratie va aussi bien
que ça donc il faut vraiment il faut
mettre toutes les chances de notre côté
pour rétablir une modernisation
démocratie inciter les gens à y aller
notamment en commençant par l'école je
suis expliquée aux gens pourquoi tous
ces mandats sont importants et puis et
puis et puis moderniser notre façon de
botter et après si ça marche toujours
pas ils sont là se pose est ce vraiment
la question
c'est un sujet sur lequel on aurait pu
parler encore longtemps on l'a vu il ya
beaucoup de notions autour de cette
abstention je propose qu'on conclut à
l'émission a maintenant la date limite
d'inscription pour le premier scrutin à
venir celui d'avril a été repoussée vous
avez jusqu'au 4 mars 2022 pour faire les
démarches le cetud société maintenant
terminer je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro et
d'ici là bien sûr prenez soin de vous
[Musique]